making his fourth start of the season
tucker davidson gets the home stand
started for atlanta and he has been
great well he's made it tough to take
him out of the lineup i'll tell you that
to give his rotation spot right now he's
earned it you see that last start one
thing i love looking at tucker first
time through the order and second time
batters are hitting 167 chip third time
through 154
martinez on deck
and that's up the middle same spot
back-to-back hits in the same spot
two beautiful swings right from the
get-go
and fighting a five-game hitting streak
for boston
this one hit in the air to straight away
center heredia will have to backpedal
gets behind the baseball makes the catch
[ __ ] hernandez is going to tag the throw
is cut off by dansby
so two out with runners at first and
third and here is bogart's the pig
got him swinging to miss
big pitch from tucker davidson there's
strikeout number one we'll see what
atlanta has come up with for the
scouting report on rafael devers 2-2
swinging a high-fly ball center field
this is deep heredia back looking up
it's gone a three-run homer they went
away from the fastball and he spanked it
here's hunter rinpro a pitch on the way
to renpro
oh swing in a deep drive this one
crushed renfro right on top of it and
that one's gone way up into the
bleachers
sox go back to back and lead it 4-0 they
are wide awake oh get the tape oh renfro
could hit him a long ways number eight
for hunter and the fifth time this
season red sox have gone back to back
eduardo rodriguez facing a big moment
here five and four with a high era 603
3-2
past him 93 miles an hour struck him out
one gone yeah nothing but gas the hole
at bat finishes it off with a fastball
swing in a miss 94 he surprised him with
that fastball
riley strikes out a lot and he will
strike out here for the 71st time
eduardo rodriguez fans three
alex verdugo skies one toward left
center heredia got a good jump
and puts it away for out number one
here's jd martinez who fly to center his
first time
that's a shot drilled out to left on the
move el monte can't reach it skips off
the wall jd heading for second base
and he's gonna round second he's on his
way into third
no throw and a triple
so tucker davidson is going to depart
after walking xander bogarts in what's
already been an injury plagued first
three months of the season for atlanta
tucker davidson has to leave with an
apparent issue through at the corners
and here's devers the man that hit the
home run
rips the first pitch into right field to
base it how hot is rafi martinez scores
and it's five
nothing red sides one two pitch on the
way got him looking strike three got a
fast ball over perfectly located one
across already here in the third one two
hit in the air to center field out
towards right center curling off his
route now backpedaling is horadia and he
will squeeze out number three about five
feet shy of the warning track
let's see if sean can lay down a bunt
he did it's pretty butt and the ball
dropped by vasquez everybody's safe
thank you very much first and third
nobody out for the dangerous ronald
acuna
got him 94 miles an hour he struck him
out for the second time here is freddy
freeman first and third one down now
hard hit and through the braves are on
the board freddie freeman with a
two-strike hit he's starting to find
some holes 36 rbis heredius scores and
the braves are on the board so it's up
to riley who struck out in the opening
inning
a little ground ball up the middle
hernandez fires on to first to retire
the side so atlanta has to settle 4-1
his pull down the line there's a good
start that'll bounce off the fence and
dansby's on his way to second with a
lead off double and here's almonte who
went down looking back in the second
inning
swinging a shot headed toward left
martinez won't get that danger he's
going to score easily that's a ground
rule double
back-to-back two base hits and the
braves are coming back it's 5-2 cunha is
coming up with a chance to tie this game
the pitch
swing and a shot headed for the gap
that's going to score one for sure
andreanz is getting the green light here
he comes relay throw is going to be late
acuna belly flops to third he's safe
it's a one-run game here comes sander
now struck out andrew will walk swinging
there's a drive to left field high and
deep way back and this ball is long gone
into the second deck xander bogarts with
a tremendous home run and it is 6-4
boston
that one punched and that one's down the
line that'll keep on rolling up against
the wall
rafael in the second
so standing up
got a renfro hit a tremendous home run
to left and walk
hunter serves that one into center field
pretty good hitting there here comes
rafael
aradia will not throw it and the red sox
add another run the rbi goes to hunter
renfro to make it 7-4 he looks hitterish
but i don't know if he can do it
here and how about that he's going to
drop in a base head into left field
get the ball
garrett whitlock and they want the
baseball his first major league hit look
at him you gotta smile when you get a
knock two guys on tying run at the plate
guillermo herrera and shoots one the
other way pastel back in the right field
of base hit here comes almonte around
third here comes renfrow's throw to the
plate it's up the line that gets away
from the catcher and herrera moves to
second on the play it's seven to five
they're loaded for acuna widlock's
one-two pitch swing and a miss 98 right
past him
base is loaded with one out freeman this
season is hitting 200 against lefties
and that one got away here comes the
runner from third there'll be no throw
contreras comes home to make it a
one-run game another defensive blunder
for boston
3-1
high fly ball to left
martinez is there
runner at third is going to tag there's
the catch here comes heredia freddie
freeman a sac fly ties the game
[Applause]
breaking ball and a single into left
field christian turned on that good way
to start the eighth inning for boston
on contact bouncing ball ozzy knocked it
down throw to first he didn't break from
third infield in saves a run that's the
second out now you figure out what you
want to do with verdugo two down second
and third for verdugo is one for four
first inning single
swinging a high fly ball center field
deep racing back her radio at the wall
gone
goodness gracious well you wanted a big
hit and you got it
incredible red sox lead it 10-7
and a shot into center field a base head
so the braves get the home ninth off to
a good start and the braves are down to
the last out best riley can do is make
it a one-run game
and a little chopper that might be
trouble endeavors charges bare hand
can't get it and aconia is going to
score from second on an infield hit
now the tying run of the plates oh
here's swanson
got him right down to shoot at 96 to end
the ball game red sox win it
10-8 the final score